How far are we allowed to go
to fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
Michael Morbius got tired of doing the whole
good guy thing, huh? what's up doc?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man Morbius trailer
video for all the sinister six stuff
that they're setting up if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a new
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your sinister six theories on the
video so the Morbius trailer shows us a
couple spider-man scenes between the
wall graffiti of the Tobey Maguire
spider-man suit referencing the Spider
Man far from home post credit scene
murderer like he killed Mysterio or at
least the world thinks he killed
Mysterio then I would argue the even
bigger scene of Michael Keaton's vulture
after the events of the spider-man
homecoming post-credit scene in his same
white prison jumpsuit in New York City
which itself might be from one of the
Morbius post-credit scenes there's also
a Kraven seemed that didn't make it into
the trailer remember we're all thinking
the Kraven might be the villain to the
next spider-man movies spider-man 3
which they're shooting this summer
there's this truck that reads teasing
that the characters going to show up Earl
soon but because it's showing up in
Morbius a Sony movie not an MCU movie
there's a big question about where
Kraven is going to appear first because
Sony is developing a Kraven solo film so
I'm not so sure that Kraven is going to be
the villain of spider-man 3 but it's
just all more evidence of them setting
up sinister 6 off in the distance in
fact on the spider-man far from home
bonus features there's a clip of Amy
Pascal literally saying that they're
getting ready to do something with the
sinister six these villains that we now
have in our universe happen to be
characters that are in the sinister six
there may be something that happens to
that no matter where he goes the world
is going to be different for him the
real blockbuster brace yourself you might
want to sit out spider-man's name is
Peter Parker
what no more hiding yeah no more hiding
I feel like you watch that and it can't
be any more clear they're definitely
headed for sinister six Sony has a
history to of putting footage from the
end of their movies in their trailers if
you didn't notice they did it with venom
last year and all the venom trailers
they kept having that clip of him
talking about turds in the wind eating
that guy in the convenience store that
was right out of the end of the venom
movie so it wasn't really them giving
away the post-credits scene it's just a
lot of people feel like this vulture
Michael Keaton cameo is from the end of
the movie like you go through the
process of him becoming the Morbius
character then this would be some sort
of tag scene to let you know that it's
all connected blowing everyone's minds
but they put it in the trailer because
they really want you to go see the movie
to find out what's going on on top of
all this there's also a lot of people
now after watching the trailer who are
wondering if Jerrod Harris's Morbius
character is in fact secretly a really
big spider-man villain from the comics
he comes off like a caring father figure
to Morbius in the trailer but Sony is
being very secretive about the official
name of his character and the only
reason to do that would be if it's a big
spoiler and if he's playing a huge
spider-man villain like a lot of people
are now wondering if he might secretly
be their new version of dr. Otto
Octavius because there are only a few
big spider-man villains who are doctors
themselves and it does seem like his
character is a medical doctor and even
though a lot of spider-man villains come
from the sciences like Norman Osborn is
a scientist he's not a real doctor in
the way Doctor Octopus is and you have
to remember that Doctor Octopus is
actually the person who put together the
first version of the sinister 6 Norman
Osborn's Green Goblin didn't really get
tied up with sinister six stuff till way
way later in the comics but they just
did the lizard a few years ago during
the Andrew Garfield amazing spider-man
movies and the whole thing with the new
Tom Hollands spider-man era of movies is
them doing new characters or people they
haven't done in a long time in yes they
did do Doctor Octopus doing the Tobey
Maguire films but if they're using
Toby's suit for this big spider-man
spider-man far from home Easter egg then
maybe it is a big clue that they're
bringing back some more stuff from the
Tobey Maguire era like the Doctor
Octopus character but now you probably
realized why they wanted to put so much
of this spider-man crossover stuff in
the Morbius movie it's mostly to get you
to go see the movie to find out what's
happening
otherwise how many people do you think
would completely ignore Morbius he's not
that huge of a character and even though
venom did really well last year venom by
himself
is a really really popular character so
people were already going to go see that
movie no matter what Sony is really
banking on this big spider verse that
they're spinning out to be successful so
they're just throwing everything they
have at these spin-off movies you never
heard of Morbius before you're not sure
about whether or not you're going to go
well we're going to put a whole bunch of
spider-man crossover stuff in it now how
about you go but cute pizza time we also
have to talk about this Tobey Maguire
spider-man costume why would they use
this version of the costume if they're
referencing the events of spider-man far
from home in that post-credit scene
would happen with Mysterio I think one
it's to let you know that there will be
a spider-man crossover eventually like
spider-man exists in this universe
because you didn't see him anywhere
during the first venom movie and I think
they're going to use the venom two - soft
reboot that with a bunch more spider-man
stuff but - I think it's also meant to
be a nod to the original Sony spider-man
movies with Tobey Maguire like those
were hugely successful films however you
feel about them creatively spider-man 2
is still one of the best spider-man
movies of all time in three I think it's
also a way to remind you that there is a
spider verse in a multiverse in a way
for the MCU movies in the Sony venom
virtue bees to coexist in how it can
make sense for Tom Holland to show up in
both franchises without the MCU having
to be super beholden to all the stuff
that they're doing in the venom movies
with top Haaland things don't really get
that complicated til you start seeing
Tom Holland jump back and forth between
the Sony movies whatever he's crossing
over with venom and he's sinister sick
stuff and then the MCU movies there's
still a lot of questions about how their
sinister six project would go down will
sinister six be the next big movie after
venom two or to Sony wait and do more
solo villain movies like the Kraven
movie I said that they're developing
they're clearly setting Kraven up during
the Morbius movies so that means that
he's going to appear somewhere but
here's what Marvel and Sony both said
about how they're handling the
spider-man Tom Holland crossovers they
announced a lot of these details when
they revealed the new sharing deal just
a little while ago they refer to it as a
call and answer system Kevin Feige
talked about spider-man jumping back and
forth between Earth's in the multiverse
but also between cinematic
versus Tom Holland was already confirmed
to be appearing in the Sony venom movies
eventually and other potentially Sony
driven spider-man projects like sinister
six when he does that Sony is allowed to
reference his previous adventures in all
the Marvel movies that spider-man has
been in like getting snapped in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame his
field trips with the Avengers during
Captain America Civil War in all the
Mysterio stuff during spider-man far
from home then when he comes back for
more Marvel movies like spider-man 3
Avengers 5 Young Avengers whatever the
MCU movies are allowed to reference all
the stuff that happened to him while he
was in the Sony venom movies so if he
gets the symbiote during one of the
venom sequels are doing a big venom
crossover they can reference the
symbiote in the MCU movies after that a
lot of you will remember way back to
spider-man homecoming the MCU movies
already kind of seemed like they were
slowly building their own roster of
sinister six characters starting in the
post-credits scene it's on our little
spider friend I've got some boys on the
outside who would just love to meet him
you don't take a picture slice his
throat but his head in a dryer and I
heard a rumor
you know here's the thing about that
post credit scene is that after the
events of spider-man far from home we
mostly assumed that we'd be seeing an
MCU only version of sinister six
but with Michael Keaton showing up at
the end of Morbius it seemingly confirms
that we'll see at least some of the
sinister six stuff come from the sony
venom verse movies so I don't know if
this is going to be a joint venture with
the MCU because sinister six is a big
deal and Sony has been trying to make a
sinister six movie since way back in the
Andrew Garfield era that was with a hole
amazing spider-man 2 post-credit scene
was about oscorp's sinister six
then Drew Goddard the person who started
the daredevil Netflix TV show was
actually going to direct the sinister six
movie but then they got rid of Andrew
Garfield and basically shelved their
plans for sinister sakes
so I still think that they're chomping
at the bit to make a sinister six movie
but because of the vulture showing up in
Morbius it seemingly confirms that venom
will also eventually have a presence in
whatever sinister six movie that they
eventually do and I think a lot of what
the new sinister six movie would wind up
looking like and how everything goes
down just depends on whether or not
Marvel makes the sinister six movie or
Sony makes it by themselves so let me
know in the comments do you think that
sinister six is going to wind up being an
MCU movie or do you think it's just
going to wind up being a Sony movie by
itself there's a bunch more Marvel
videos I'll be doing this weekend and
next week so leave all your requests in
the comments below if you have any big
questions
congratulations kyrie irving you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so we can get your details
everyone click here to rewatch the full
Morbius trailer a billion more times and
every one click here to watch the
Justice League Ezra Miller flash
crossover with a Grant Gustin flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!